and i'm talking to a guy named daniel
who came here from costa rica to add me
on his podcast and he says uh
you know what do you think needs to
happen long term for free thinkers like
yourself
to be able to stay you know relevant and
all this stuff so listen
here's how the war was won okay and it's
still going on the battle's still going
on but you got to give props to
democrats
a ton of props to these democrats right
how was it one okay you can go all the
way back they say woodrow wilson is the
time when the school changed from
what it was to what it is today and that
was a hundred years ago 1913 is what 110
100 or seven years ago right
three workers yeah exactly so you go
back to that you say okay so republicans
were like hey we're gonna go on
real estate we're gonna own companies
we're gonna we're gonna own oil we're
gonna make money that's what we're gonna
do
leave us alone with the money when you
think oil you don't think democrats you
think oil you think
republicans when you think military you
think republicans when you think there's
certain things that you think
church republicans you go there right
okay and church
was a big influence to him it's not not
as much as what it used to be but it's a
lot it's a lot of influence they had
right okay so democrats being closed
doors says
you can have that uh we'll go win over
colleges universities school curriculum
books ideology ideology and then they
said well social media is also going to
go on
social media media newspaper magazines
i'm telling you guys i was a big like
just six years ago it sounds like it
made old school versus news
six years ago i made a video talking
about the you know what business
magazines i read and i went through
i no longer buy money magazine i no
longer buy fortune magazine
i no longer subscribe i went through a
list of financial times don't
waste your financial times as decent
yeah i went through a list and said i no
longer
purchase any of these i've been i was i
bought every single month they came out
i bought them right
i no longer do why because the articles
are being written by journalists who
have never ran a business and never made
the money and they're just kind of
giving their opinions
based on what they think is the right
thing and they're bashing rich people
they're bashing the dream the dream of
being financially free is being bashed
today
like it's a bad thing there used to be
time you're like oh my gosh look at that
guy
he started as a nobody now he's got a
nice house he's got a nice family he's
made the money he's traveling the world
he's going to the games he's sitting
next to oh man one day i want to be but
today that person
is i don't want to tell anybody that
became successful and i went from
nothing to somebody because if people
find that i have money
oh my gosh pull down stats yeah so you
don't build statutes
the complete opposite so here's the
moral of the story the moral of the
story is long-term
long-term um i said to him
if these guys bought la times they
bought money magazine
forbes was a you know capital it was the
last standing
magazine that protected capitalist sold
to china
95 only 5 is owned by the forbes family
if this was an incredible business
magazine i would have bought a forbes
type of a brand but
at this point you think the chinese
media company is going to sell forbes
brand to anybody else if you make an
offer
for what it's actually worth they're
probably going to ask you much more if
you want to pay for it
but so they had a they had the
opportunity to buy you were twitter
years ago they had an opportunity to buy
twitter they had an opportunity every
one of these things were for sale
youtube were for sale all of these
things were for sale
they don't buy it republicans said no
we're going to go buy only we're going
to go
sleep they were sleeping were asleep and
they lost influence and you got to give
props
to whoever wins you can say whatever you
can the time that
mayweather won the fight where victor's
looking this way and boom he punched him
and knocked him out and it's like what
are you doing you shouldn't punch
he says listen once you say go it's
fight
so mayweather just capitalized and uh
today republicans are sitting there
saying we lost influence what do we do
next it says a lot
that the smartest political move the
republicans have made in like the last
20 years has been to shut up for 100
days and let democrats talk
like that's it like you know people are
finally starting to listen to what the
left is saying
whoa whoa this is crazy this is this
critical race three stuff is insane this
is nuts
and the the it's really an indictment of
the republicans that
the best argument that they could make
is just to stop talking like that's
like and even now you got marginally
margaery green taylor out there and
you know the entire media wants to put
the lens on that they're going to turn
her into the wright's aoc
you know as if she's somehow
representative of the group as a whole
but it's
yeah they they lost you're you're spot
on
they lost a culture war that they didn't
even recognize was happening
they lost the culture war that they
didn't even know they were so far asleep
at the wheel
they got so old and so complacent and
again i think this
those same people are doing this with
bitcoin again to bring this full circle
but
the they lost the war that they didn't
even recognize was happening
well that's when you see a picture of
like trump standing around 400 old white
men and that's the republican party
you're like well i don't know if that's
the best approach and now you have
people like candace owens or like
charlie kirk or you have younger people
or
tim poole or whoever you want to put in
there that are like speaking out of
being more vulnerable
that's the problem when you have just
the male pale and snail crowd giving
everything that they have new
republicans are people who left the
democrats that's their big
thing right our big thing like i'm a
libertarian right and our big thing
is you know the left did this
i left the left i started as a democrat
in college and then i
met democrats and you know the
performative nature of like the hardcore
left i was just like nah that's not
no no no i'm not no i'm not i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna hold hands and block
traffic i'm not gonna like you know what
i'm saying
yeah so i'm like if those are me then
i'm not them
you know and and it's just like where's
the moderate anymore man like
thank god for joe manchin you want me to
say something good about that don't even
get me started on joe manchin
joe manchin is the most important man in
america no one even knows his name
this guy has i'm this is going to sound
similar to the man of the year time
this guy has single-handedly
held our union together if he
would have gone party line and dc would
be a state
and they would eliminate the filibuster
and they would have would have
eliminated the second amendment
florida would be a country right now
texas would be a country right now let
me ask you a question
let me ask you union together let me ask
you a weird question how much longer
until
we hear about something he did 40 years
ago without all right
how much longer until we hear nine women
coming how much longer until an email
from 17 years ago
how much is it already no i disagree
it's going to happen
people who have common sense and they
don't just say i'm a leftist i'm a right
i'm a republican
he's a democrat in freaking west
virginia yeah
the redistricting the country look at
what they did and he continuously gets
elected
look at what that's
look at what they're left at the tulsi
avenue it's um
look the entire universe
for common sense the entire universe
kamala she should have ended kamala
she basically did and kamal and then
they you know they just described her
yeah so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you